hackers are hell-bent on disrupting our
lives they have already targeted fuel
supplies
a major meat producer and transportation
networks top biden officials are telling
americans
to get used to it which means they can't
solve the problem
warning it could get a lot worse
the first thing we have to recognize is
this is the reality
and we should assume and businesses
should assume
that these attacks are here to stay and
if anything will intensify
do you think that adversaries of the
united states
have the capability right now to shut
down the power grid
uh yeah they do there are thousands of
attacks on
all aspects of the energy sector and the
private sector generally
it's happening all the time scary
and former director of national
intelligence john ratcliffe says america
is falling behind in cyber security
there's a gaping hole in our cyber
defense and that hole is called the
department of homeland security
by law the department of homeland
security has the authority to
defend our networks against domestic
attacks but authority is not capability
and you know unfortunately i think most
folks in the government stopped
arguing a long time ago about this is
that guy on the left
so dana uh they recovered a 2.3 million
million dollar million dollars worth of
bitcoin
from colonial pipeline that was the
ransomware
although to me ransomware sounds like
something you might put on if you were
planning on being kidnapped
right you never know especially grab the
ransomware you never know it's usually
some kind of
famous flirty halter top okay
so is this enough just to take the the
crypto shouldn't you be putting them in
the crypto
yes in the crypt so secretary romando
yes she basically was saying um yeah
uh it's really important for us to be
prepared right okay no we know that
yes we've known that for many many years
a general jack keane this morning on a
newsroom said
that we actually as a government have
the capability to
push back right so it sounds like one
we did today in terms of getting that
crypto back but
also it would be helpful i think if the
administration said and
america will not stand for this yeah
it's a declaration of war we will kill
you like a terrorist
yes exactly okay that was the other
point i wanted to make for years you've
made the point about the concern taking
terrorism
and bio terror and putting them together
right right imagine that
plus the wars that we are we are in i
think that we are in a cyber war right
now
because those are attacks against actual
people and that's that's the
new war that we're all going to have to
be fighting and put all these resources
into it yeah
putting anthrax or something on a drone
and letting it go over a
a football game yeah that's pretty easy
to do sean what are your
you so you know about the bitcoin stuff
probably more than all of us combined
because you have some
i have some yeah so what do you what do
you make of this new kind of activity
this new kind of crime
we'll leave bitcoin alone for a second
i'm a huge fan but here to your point i
think we have to get aggressive this is
an attack on our sovereignty right
now there's a role for uh our businesses
to protect their
their uh their infrastructure and and
keep themselves
to keep them safe from attackers but i
view this we should send in seals
right so you have you know 22 year old
kids in the pajamas in their basement
doing their thing on their computer
seals show up boom boom boom guess what
no more attacks right they can do it
right they can attack us
but they won't because they'll get you
know a knock into the head
yeah right and that's the way you stop
these attacks on our country and frankly
i don't think putin is gonna play ball
putin is not gonna hold these uh hackers
accountable
so it's gonna be the u.s government that
holds these little bad actors and these
little pods in these
dirty little countries accountable for
what they're doing to our country by the
way this is a real risk
you shut down our electric grid people
die right
it's really serious but there must be
something that putin can get from us
like that pipeline i mean that that was
interesting timing that the pipeline all
of a sudden was it was okay to have that
what's it called cross wins or whatever
streamed nordstrom sounds like a camper
but anyway so that happened uh uh
geraldo if we could tie these attacks to
white supremacists
with the white house or immigration tied
to immigration yes
but you know yesterday was uh june 6th
and you uh commemorated the 77th
anniversary of the d-day storming of
d-day uh this is war this is war as much
as uh
as that was war you know it's bio it's
uh
germ it's uh all these it and bitcoin is
so untraceable
bitcoin is made for criminals with all
due respect you are esteemed colleague
john she just called you a criminal i i
just think that
it's it's nuts they should have like
bitcoin that explode and
leave like a die on the hands of the
users the way uh
some bank deposits do but i think it's
very troubling and i don't know what the
hell to do
about it i i can't even figure out my
password half the time
his password no
yes but i i i fear for the future unless
we take the pajama wearing kid
and set them loose to defend us rather
than to attack us yeah you know katie i
always notice a trend with dems
democrats when they say
a problem is here to stay right it's the
one they can't fix
they will never say that about climate
change or any other thing or
systemic racism if you said to them you
know systemic racism is here to stay
they'd be like no it's not we have to do
everything yeah it sounds like there's a
group of people that need to learn to
code so yeah they can help the country
uh combat cyber attacks and that's
something that the government needs but
this argument of
saying we just need to get used to being
attacked is so antithetical to what the
federal government's
job is the left and democrats think the
federal government has a role for
everything but when it comes to problems
that
they maybe want to downplay expectations
for if we get attacked again they
say well just get used to doing it but
think of it as it's hard to
think of it in a tangible way because
it's digital but say we had
an oil tanker that was attacked off of
the coast of somalia by pirates and
terrorists right
the company would hire security but the
government the united states military
would then take on uh projects projects
to get rid of terrorists who were
attacking u.s interests whether they
were private or military targets no
matter where they are
in the world we've seen this uh you know
all over the place
africans are private citizens and we
still go exactly
so the government has an obligation to
fight this from
a level of military force and sending in
some navy seals or
some delta force guys might send the
right message to these people to not
carry out terrorist attacks especially
on critical infrastructure here in the
states
and when it comes to putin i think that
the the attack on the meat packing
company happened actually after
nordstrom 2 was pushed
through and so it doesn't it doesn't
really matter unless there's force
involved or there's a consequence from a
government not just security from a
private company
it's going to keep happening the biggest
problem is insurance
it's cheaper for the company to pay the
ransom because they're insured
right you got to outlaw that insurance
that's how you get it it might be less
expensive if they actually invested in
protecting their systems
right right but they but that's they do
the way the bet costs are benefits and
they think it's cheaper that way
meanwhile what
about a personal what if it's you that
is being extorted like you have
i've been thinking about this like let's
uh or you're thinking about those
pictures you took back in the 90s
they're up in the cloud they're up in
the cloud somebody gets a hold of it
could be a person-to-person extortion
thing and you're
like if a kid gets extorted is he gonna
tell his parents
that they're no he's gonna if he's gonna
freak out he could
harm himself that's what scares me is
that that that can
happen more and more not did i have
anything on the cloud
i'll send you twenty dollars my
allowance yes
send them the bitcoin that's worth more
all right up next major hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else